yeah thank you good morning everybody
welcome to
all in the room committee members of the
public and offices
and to those who are viewing on youtube
welcome
on the touring youtube site um
to this plans committee meeting of the
third of june
i'll ask the committee to introduce
themselves first of all
and then the officers are really the
technics so if we can start at the far
end there
richard wiseman i represent
good morning uh pete christie
representing benefit north good morning
my name is steve mcgoff and i
also represent bit of food good morning
i'm chris levin and i represent noah
good morning sean mountain planning
manager
good morning my name is damian i'm the
biggest services manager
good morning my name is james jackson
i'm a principal planner at torridge
district council
and good morning matt collins county
council highways
list for a fire drill when we meet in
the channel the five really is that
you're going through the
entrances that you came in through but
don't use the lift
and we did a fire alarm went off at the
last meeting so
i hope we don't get one this
do we know somebody can use it now
because i think they didn't yeah it
could have been
there we could lower you out of the
window
we'll get you outdoors right we'll we'll
move on with the agenda then
uh item one on the agenda is apologies
yes chair an apology from texas
with council language substitution and
i'd just like to say
councillor craig he did have a mountain
accident yesterday
and i did contact her and leave her a
message and i think
from what langford has said she's all
right
just a big shake though welcome to
council of langford this morning
item number two on the agenda is
declarations of interest
members with interest to declare should
refer to the agenda item and describe
the nature
of their interests when the item is
being considered
elected members of devon county council
and town and parish councils
who've considered a planning application
by virtue of their membership of that
council
hold a personal interest and are deemed
to have considered the application
separately and the express views of that
council do not find the members
concerned
who consider the application afresh
item three on the agenda is agreements
of the agenda between part one and two
is no part two agenda item four on the
agenda is urgent matters
i have nothing convergent two uh
matters to bring up but if playing
georgia has the planning manager
so we move in uh item five
on the agenda's public participation and
we've had
a request from
nine members of the public to speak four
to the first application
at bloody corner and northern
two to speak to the digital road apple
door application
and three to speak to the whole
bradford application
item six on the agenda is planning
applications
the information recommendations and
advice contained in the records
any reports are correct at the date of
preparation
which is more than 10 days in advance of
the committee regime
due to these time constraints any
changes
or necessary updates to the reports will
be provided in writing
or orally at the committee meeting
and 6a on the agenda is our first
planning application
and that is on pages 39
to 52 of your report
and planning officer james jackson will
present this
application thank you thank you chair
uh good morning members good morning
members of the public watching on
youtube
um as the chair says this is application
one slash zero six
zero four slash twenty twenty
uh it's an outline application for 39
dwellings with almost reserve accept
access
at the site known as land at bloody
corner in northern
in devon just a couple of verbal
updates first of all before the
presentation um just in terms of
representation
received since uh the publication of the
agenda
now we've just received 12 further
objections
uh to the proposal which i can summarize
as follows for you
uh in terms of the issues raised they're
harm to the undeveloped coast
that the benefits significantly
demonstrably outweigh
uh are outweighed by the harm associated
with the proposal
the setting of precedent the issue of
coalescence
harm to the battlefield site impact on
tourism
protection of green space traffic
congestion and highway safety
over development impact on character and
appearance
loss of agricultural fields increased
light and noise pollution
impact on infrastructure and local
amenities and lack of social housing
and local housing second homes
issue impact on biodiversity
the proposal is contrary to policy that
the site is outside the development
boundary
and the uh case law indicates that the
application should be refused
um just for the purposes of
the recommendation obviously these these
issues have been taken into account were
raised previously by a number objections
and it doesn't alter your uh officer's
recommendation in terms of its
applications
uh moving on just another verbal update
to uh the suggested condition nine which
is the written scheme of investigation
uh as drafted in the agenda on page
35 uh the
the condition is such that no
development shall take place until
a wsi has been submitted and approved by
the local tango authority
um just to clarify this has been
reviewed some time ago by
dcc's historic environment um officer
um and deemed to be acceptable by that
officer
the issue then was that the applicant
never submitted that wsi to the local
planning authority
um although they have done so in more
recently so
obviously that was reviewed and approved
some time ago by the
senior officer so the suggested moment
to that condition is that the
development should be
undertaken in accordance with that
submitted wsi
reference am 0 2 2 9 revision b dated
25th to the 11th
20th uh obviously that would only be
relevant if if
members were minded to support the
application and resolve the ground
subject to the 106. okay so moving on to
the uh presentation uh next slide please
uh here we have the site location plan
on the left and
the an aerial image on the right site
location
plan shows the site outlined in red with
other land
uh owned by the applicant outlined in
blue uh
as we can see it's an over two open
parcels of land we've got a
uh footpath running through the middle
of those two parcels and then
east-west direction there's also another
public right-of-way running down
the western boundary of the southernmost
parcel there
as you can see from there we have um the
site ordering
existing residential development on its
western and southern edges
with agricultural fields to the north
and to the east
next slide please
so i just thought it was useful to
provide a bit of a wider context one
the aerial image on the left we can see
the site annotated by the blue dot down
in uh towards the bottom of that image
and then we have the existing urban area
of northern over to the west
and the ecuador urban area over to the
north
east there and i just thought it'd be
worthwhile showing you
the development boundary which um is on
the right hand
side of that slide there and then this
side edged
um in red there as well just so you can
see the relationship
of of the site to the development
boundary obviously
as i'll go into the site does lie
outside the development boundary
and there is a policy relating to
coalescence between
northern and appledore which is relevant
in terms of the consideration
of the application today
next slide slightly so this is an
indicative site plan
uh as i said at the start is the
application is in outline form and all
monsters reserved accept access
so members are not considering the
layout appearance
scale or landscaping today this
literally just shows
the site and demonstrates how the 39
proposed dwellings could be laid out on
the site and
it does also show the pedestrian and
vehicle access
which is for consideration today as part
of the application the vehicle access is
shown there through
the western site boundary going on to
green april close
and we also have a couple of uh
pedestrian accesses as well through
onto from the southern parcel of the
site
onto the existing footpath that bisects
the site
next slide please this is the indicative
sections again this is based on the
indicative site plans and again this is
not consideration today but it just
shows
members what if there were money to
grant um
uh planning permission today that what
the
sections could look like in terms of
that layout so here we have
the red line shows the uh the existing
ground levels
and up on the right hand side of those
sections we've got the existing
properties on windmill lane
and then the remainder of those uh
drawings those images are on those built
form
uh next slide please so here on the left
hand side we have the proposed vehicle
access on screen okay close uh we have a
5.5 meter wide carriageway with a two
meter footwear either side
uh 43 meters visibility as is required
within
uh this location um and obviously
here that would necessitate the
removable a few individual free
specimens
and the bank uh in in whole greenhouse
gas
on the right we have um the proposed two
meter wide footway
uh on the a836 and
churchill way this is outside bloody
corner running up towards the north
next slide please i just thought it'd be
useful to run you through some of the
lvia viewpoints as well as well as some
photographs that i've taken as well
this just shows a map of where the
viewpoints have been um
taken from we have one over in insto and
then another one on the eastern side of
the
estuary as well and then some to the
north of the site and there's some
closer into the site as well i'll take
you through each of those now
next slide please so this is the first
view from insto
the blue line at the top of the
photograph there
shows the location of the site beneath
it
next slide please this is view two
from the eastern bank of the estuary um
adjacent to the jetty
this is view three from one pit hill
churchill away this is just that side
fairway which is the notre dame just
near to broad lane i think it is
next slide please this is from windmill
lane looking back
um more closely to the site now looking
back across the site in a
north westerly direction
this is view six so this is within green
acre close looking east so this is
looking back at the proposed access
and sort of just at the end of that
picture there where those where the
existing trees are
looks like things this is view seven so
this is from the a386 looking east back
towards bloody corner
please this is view eight this is 386
church away looking back towards the
site there on the left hand side
uh looking safe next slide please
so just a few photographs here these two
are of the existing agricultural small
holding that currently occupies
the northern part of the site
this is taken from the southwest corner
of the site
in the public right-of-way this is
looking
along with the existing footpath the
public rights away and also across the
site
side please this is looking back across
from the footpath that runs between the
two classes of land this is looking over
to existing development on green acre
close on the left hand side
and up to existing development on
windmill lane on the right-hand side
there
and the one on the left here is the
existing public right way
that runs between the two passes of land
ultimately takes you down to the
southwest coast path and the estuary
and on the right hand side there is
another shot of the proposed access
without
letting us park there next slide please
and one on the left is green acre close
looking west
the one on the right is green close
looking up towards windmill main on the
slope now
next slide the
photograph on the left here is looking
uh west along with mill lane
uh photographing the center shows the
the footway existing footwear um a
bloody corner looking
north and that's where the proposed two
meter wide footwear would be
constructed and photograph on the far
right
is the bloody warner memorial stain
next slide please so material
considerations
in this case are principle of
development landscape character of
visual impact
heritage and ecology right archaeology
residential amenity
biodiversity highways flood risk and
surface water drainage
and infrastructure as you've seen from
your offices report
and as we seen previously
the local planning authority currently
cannot and demonstrate a five-year
supply of housing land as found in the
beerwood inquiry
um this means that we have to undertake
the tilted balance and that is for
members of consideration today to
determine
whether or not the obvious impacts
associated with the development
significantly and did not should be
outweigh
the benefits this also involves
policy st 21 to being engaged
also as as found in the burwood inquiry
these matters are all set out in your
offices report um
there is uh there are some benefits
obviously proposal in terms of
revision of 39 dwellings should be given
in your office's view significant weight
and we have the associated benefits as
well with
30 of the scheme being affordable homes
a number of financial contributions to
mitigate the impact of the development
biodiversity net gain also economic
benefits
associated with the creation of 39
households within the
local economy um and then turning to the
harm
there is harm identified in terms of the
proposal is within the undeveloped coast
um
policy sto97 um
sets out that that
development should only be located in
the
undeveloped coast where it's not
possible for it to be located in the
developed coast
as has set out in your report there is
some conflict with that
um policy and it's members to apportion
a degree of harm to that
we also have landscape character and
visual impact harm
which is in your offices where you quite
localize
the site itself you've seen the lbi
images there as well
um so that is also a degree of harm
there
and also the setting of the
bloody corner memorial stone the
council's
conservation officers indicated in her
comments that that harm is less than
substantial
and that that needs to be weighed
against any public benefit associated
with the proposal
so it's for members obviously to weigh
all of those competing issues against
one another in terms of the benefits and
uh and harms and come to review as i
said in terms of the tilted balance as
to whether
those harms significantly and
demonstrably outweigh the benefits
associated with the proposal
and in your office's view uh those
benefits are not significantly
intellectually outweighed with the
result it is recommended that
on planning permission be granted
subject to the section 106 agreement
which would secure
the affordable housing and the um
financial contributions set out to
report totaling some
nearly 200 thousand pounds
thank you jeff thank you james that
completes the presentation and our
there's public speaking now and our
first public speaker
is mr keith goodridge speaking against
the application
if you'd like to take the planning
offices
see please mr
could all the planning committee hear
the presentation all right
good morning mr goodwood good morning
you have
three minutes to present to the
committee family good morning
councillors my name is keith goodwin a
retired tournament country planet with
over 30 years experience
and i'm also representing the outdoor
residence association
today you are being asked to agree the
officer's recommendation that the
benefits of this housing development
are not outweighed by the environmental
harm caused
the so-called tilted balance
unfortunately you have not been provided
with
all the correct information you need to
make this decision
you're told about the burywood torrent
and appeal and the five-year housing
supply deficit
but not told that that site did not have
a protected valued landscape
as has the bloody corner side and this
may well have resulted in a different
conclusion by the inspector you've been
given a report that when assessing
compliance with the local band's overall
vision
development strategy it focuses on
sustainable locations for housing
that badly detects the importance of the
environment
this includes protecting important
landscapes and especially the
undeveloped coast
necessary as set out in the local plan
policy sc09
backed by national planning policy
framework
you are told that the adverse impact on
the undeveloped coast is minor
but not told that this conclusion is
based on the applicant's fatally flawed
landscape report
which incredibly makes no reference at
all to the undeveloped coast
and the four policy tests which must be
applied when considering the impact of
development
you are told in a report that in
accordance with policy stm9
the site could reasonably be located
outside the undeveloped post
with no loss of pounding benefit
benefits and no lost protective
landscape
but this conclusion is then not followed
through
you are effectively told that proposals
won't contribute to coalescence
making a mockery of the council's local
plan policy nor
age when it is irrefutable that this
development would contribute
to closing the northern ecuador gap you
are given conclusions which fail to
quantify the environmental
community costs including the cost of
losing these valued protected fields
which contribute to the character and
identity of the two settlements they
help separate
the cost in quality of life for local
residents
who pass this prominent tranquil rural
fields
every day and the cost to the northern
devons tourism economy
as this finite finite and vital asset of
the undeveloped coast
is further eroded a vote for this
proposal sends a clear message to
developers that this council has thrown
in the tower
on local plan strategy for the
undeveloped coast including policies
sg09
and north h and the area between
northern and april can now be built on
whatever the environmental costs
now you have all the facts please make
the right decision and infuse this
application on the basis
that the advantages of housing
development are significantly and
demonstrably
outweighed by the harmful to the
countryside
the undeveloped coast the remaining and
the remaining gap we can find
northern ecuador as separate settlements
thank you very much
our next contribution is a statement
which
the planning manager will read out from
gareth cross
thank you a statement from gareth cross
do your planning committee i would like
to write in to have an objection read
out about the planning committee if
possible
st09 st 14 north devlin torridge
2011 to 2031 local plan st09 states
development within the undeveloped coast
and estuary will be supported
where it does not detract from the
unspoken character appearance and
tranquility
of the area normally undeveloped
character of the hairdresser's coasts
and it is required because it cannot
reasonably be located
outside the undeveloped coast and
estuary
this proposal fails on two of the
criteria quoted in the local plan
section st09
these 39 houses could easily be built in
the thousands of acres of land
in land there is no need for more
housing in this protected area
it will detract from the tranquility and
appearance of the area
this field forms part of the popular
walking route connecting the estuary to
the village
it is also very visible for traffic
coming up the road from applegall
it invades the green gap between north
and avatar
there are no long-term jobs associated
with more housing
and no useful tourism developments which
may have committed this development
under section sg09 moving on to section
st 14 i have quoted this in its entirety
below
as this development fails to satisfy any
of the criteria
that may have allowed it to be passed
in short this proposal is totally in
contradiction in the local plan
if it is passed then this committee may
as well throw out the entire local
development plan
as allowing this development to go ahead
will contravene it entirely
it will also encourage other landowners
along this protected zone
to try their hand at a planning
application and we will lose our
distinctive
landscape for future generations
it then goes on to quote policy st-14 in
its entirety and chair would you like me
to meet our cst14
um policy st-14 enhancing environmental
assets the quality of north devon's
natural environment
will be protected and enhanced by
ensuring that development contributes to
a providing a net gain in northern
devon's biodiversity where possible
through positive management of an
enhanced and expanded network of
designated sites
and green infrastructure including
retention and enhancement of critical
environmental capital
b protecting the hierarchy of designated
sites
in accordance with their status c
conserving european protected species
and habitats in which they depend
d conserving northern devon's geo
diversity
and its best and most versatile
agricultural land
e conserving the setting and special
character in qualities of the north
daring coast areas
and of outstanding natural beauty whilst
fostering the social and economic
well-being of the area
f ensuring development conserves and
enhances
northern devon's local distinctiveness
including its tranquility
and the setting and special qualities of
x1 national park
including dark night skies g
protecting and enhancing local
landscapes and sea skate character
taking into account the key
characteristics the historical dimension
of the landscape and their sensitivity
to change
page recognizing the importance of the
undeveloped coast
estrang and marine environments through
supporting designations
plans and policies that aim to protect
and enhance northern devon's coastline
i conserving and enhancing the robust
robustness of northern devon's
ecosystems
and the range of ecosystem services they
provide
jay increasing our opportunities for
access
education and appreciation of all
aspects of norway devon's environment
for all sections of the community okay
meeting the natural improvement areas
strategic objectives
and eye so now improving
failing water bodies and preventing
deterioration of water quality
yours faithfully gareth cross thank you
we think you've lost it screaming
thank you our next speaker in support of
the application is russell williams
the age if you'd like to come up to the
microphone
please mr williams
[Music]
awarding me and you have three minutes
to address the committee
thank you thank you chairman i'd like to
take this opportunity to thank mr
jackson for his assistance throughout
the application process
and his thorough report that's before
members this morning with a
recommendation for approval
as your officer has identified
northbound is a
sustainable assessment and the site is
well related to
services facilities and public transport
regions in the area
we consider the development of 39
dwellings to be sustainable on the whole
and a natural rounding off of the built
environment to the eastern edge of
auburn
we've recognized that the area of bloody
corner has a sensitive history to it
and this is reflected by the extensive
survey investigations undertaken
regarding heritage and archaeology
the detailed archaeological
investigations have confirmed confirm
there have been no discernable impact
upon
heritage assets the county archaeologist
has no objections
and has approved the written scheme of
investigation which has been submitted
to the council
we acknowledge the concerns raised by
members of the public regarding the post
access
but it is pertinent sorry to note that
the highway authority of assess the
scheme
are satisfied that the transport impacts
of the development will be acceptable
the affordable housing provision meets
local plan requirements and this will be
secured by section 106 agreement
together with contributions towards
education and health services highway
improvements open space
and recreation the development will make
a viable contribution towards the many
objectives outlined within spatial
policies
and this is an important consideration
when assessing future housing delivery
it also complies with policy st20 st21
and the development is in a location
and is of a scale and a nature that is
commensurate with the housing needed
in the area regarding delivery law room
is a popular area to live
and our extensive experience within the
local development land markets
indicates that this cycle will be sought
after
amongst house builders indeed we've
already received a number of inquiries
from house builders and we're confident
cycle sales swiftly on the grounds of
planning permission
and it will be built up built but
apology would be built out quickly
thereafter
assisting with the housing need within
the area you will have noted that there
are no objections raised by any of the
technical consulties
and this should be very pertinent to
your decision this morning
this application should be determined
with a with a presumption in favor of
sustainable development
the reasons already mentioned and is set
out in your professional offices report
the development the development is
sustainable on the whole and the
benefits of the scheme the moderately
outweighing
any limited time has been identified i
therefore respectfully
ask members to support your professional
officer's recommendation this morning
and to round out like that thank you
thank you
[Music]
our final speaker this morning is
councillor haynes
who's a award member from the
neighboring board of applicable
councilmen foreign councils
yeah good morning councillors thank you
chair for letting me speak as an apple
door award member
together with the many people in my
awards have objected to this application
and also northern town council i'm
extremely concerned about the committee
report recommendation to approve
which is based on showing a five-year
housing supply because of the decision
that the burn of torrington appealed
however i must emphasize that the two
sites are totally different
unlike burn wood which had no special
protection from strategic policies the
bloody corner site does have such
protection
and should be subject to two tests in
the relevant policy
st21 regarding managing the delivery of
housing
under these tests criteria c and d
the application should conform with the
strategic policies and spatial policy
which aim to protect the landscape from
proposals which harm it
and which state that development that
will contribute to coalescence
between northern and ecuador shall be
resisted
however the officer doesn't seem to
follow the requirements of these
policies
he comes up with a brand new
interpretation of the strategic policy
norh
where he says that because existing
development on the western side of
church away
leaves a narrower gap between the
built-up areas of northern and april
than the bloody corner site then the
application
before you does not contribute to
coalescence
this seems to be nonsense as clearly
developing the six acres of bloody corn
that will contribute to closing the gap
between the two settlements
this flawed definition of what
constitutes coalitions
coalescence has huge implications
because it would open up
large areas of land to the east of
churchill way
to development and elsewhere on the
basis of
norh applies only to the narrowest gap
during settlements
this would make the policy weak and
ineffective
and greatly discredit an important part
of the local plan
what is more the applicant's landscape
consultant
ignores the protection that local plan
policy sto9
and also nppf para 170
give this side because of its
designation as undeveloped
coast this policy is supposed to protect
the undeveloped coastal development
which has an adverse
impact and yet incredibly the whole
landscape and visual appraisal with the
application is based on the site having
no such protection
it contains no reference to the
undeveloped coast and therefore there is
no assessment of the site
under the criteria s209 regarding the
impact of the development on the
character appearance and tranquility of
the site
and also the surrounding area the lvia
was therefore badly flawed worse still
is that the officer uses the report to
conclude
that the impact on the site in the
surrounding countryside
would amount to minor harm even though
he states that it's contrary to sto9
it is glaringly obvious that a high
density hillside development in the
undeveloped coast
overlooking a beautiful valley which is
also in the undeveloped coast
is bound to fail the tests of harm in
sti 9
and that the hum will be major
as on the side it is interesting to note
here that developers lvix always take
place when the trees are relief and
views are obscured
and they always say the effect on views
which you can't actually see in either
as the proposed development is 39 houses
it won't affect five year houses by one
way or another
and crucially the officer himself admits
that it can be built on another site
which means that it fails yet another
test of policy s209
that the development is required because
of course it can't reasonably be located
outside the end of the undeveloped
coastal history
oh yes and there's no guarantee of any
affordable houses either
the problem is that by ignoring sto9 and
the harm to the character of the site
and landscape
and by weakening policy no rh the
officer is just
dismissing the local planned vision and
strategic policies for northern
and the undeveloped coast and giving the
green light
for potentially hundreds of houses north
or south of the narrowest part of the
gap
not exactly a trivial matter in fact the
officer's arguments even undermine the
committee
report for the next application before
you at diddy world and
where the impact on the undeveloped
coast is used as a reason for refusal
turning to highways after seeing the
site do you really agree with the
applicant
on highways officer that there are no
highway safety issues
and adequate visibility at the junction
of windmill lane
and churchill way do you really think
that allowing an extra 230 traffic
movements is a good idea
do you really think that you already
committed developments to wooder road
and that
won't make a bad situation even worse
local people in my ward and elsewhere
are increasingly in concern about being
involved in an accident
as they drive up the hill to the blind
bend which obscures the windmill lane
junction
the situation which is not held by cars
entering the leaving a car car next to
that junction
and of course you'll have noted the
overwhelming concerns expressed
expressed by residents of windmill lane
and green acre close
about the dangers at that junction
councillors if you really want to uphold
their own strategic policies
are respectfully asking to refuse this
application
the office has tilted the ballots
towards approval
by neglecting to apply the vital
strategic policies designed to protect
the local environment
furthermore by improving the application
it will make it hard to refuse future
housing development that will
permanently harm the highly valued
undeveloped coast and which would also
close the gap between north and ethanol
this will be totally against the wishes
of local people who are desperate to
protect the remaining countryside
please remember this is what the public
said they wanted
during the consultation period for the
local plan
and also for the northern neighbourhood
plan
to which i should point out your
chairman contributed extensively
and which has at its heart the
prevention of coalescence and the
protection of cherished green spaces
thank you for listening thank you
councillor
that's our last speaker and so now it's
for the
committee to debate and we'll start off
by
stating that this application is an open
market
led residential development if the
airplane commission is granted the
applicant
will try to sell on the site to a
developer
the only consideration for determination
today is the access
with all of the considerations for the
reserve matters stage for a reserve bank
stage um so all that's mentioned about
affordable housing and two hundred
thousand pounds
of finance is only a wish list it's not
comfort any of that isn't confirmed
thirty-nine dwellings should provide
11.7 affordable
but with no indication of a viability
assessment
of the site taking into consideration
the other section 106 contributions
that are sold so i'll open it to the
committee to debate
and counsel mcgoff is first to speak
thank you mr chairman mr
can i go back to the slide please the
outline of the site
yeah i just want to see that again
please and also can we go to the one at
wimble
lane that green egg are close where the
engine was going to be at the end
where do you have the cars parked there
the ones with the cars like that he's
not
not the one without your cars yes
thank you much all right thank you much
mr chairman thanks for showing their
slides
um i'm going to go straight in for it
and
propose that we refuse this application
on the grounds that is on the
undeveloped coast and a coastal history
strategy of stl 9
and obviously the harm of st-14 as well
by
the residential immediacy is a real key
for me this to me
looking at this and that is demonstrable
harm to the residential
the residential immunity and that's
obviously dmo one as well
and obviously the biodiversity doa so my
proposal is refuse this application
regardless of if we haven't got a five
year bill supply my main crux of it is
the undeveloped coast and obviously the
coaching history strategy stm9
i don't think this applications should
be here today so my thing is
thank you councilman goff council
christian
okay well i'll second that and the
reasons are very obvious i think because
councilman's office will spout them out
um it's a very odd report because
at the very bottom of page 25 taking
account of all the above that's all the
various policies which is the officer's
view that the proposal is contrary to
our local plan policies and he sets them
up
you turn over notwithstanding is policy
complex
the officer says that we should go ahead
with it i haven't seen that before
where the officer actually quotes all
the policies we need to quote to turn it
down
and then basically says you can ignore
them we've heard from councillor haines
this is
very different to burwood uh it is an
undeveloped coastal area
um the houses could be built elsewhere
we know that and it does form part of
the green wedge between
uh northern and ecuador we're not bound
by this five-year
land supply nonsense it is there it
tells us
you know we have to follow where we can
but it's not a rule
that we always bow down before the two
other points i would make
and i don't know if we can see it
actually because i don't know if tom can
go back to
uh the google earth map
or google earth slide you had i don't
know if it'd be possible to blow this up
because
i was looking at this uh
yeah it's going to be very difficult
it's very i was looking at this last
night on my
computer and if you look unfortunately
it's a blue dot right across it
i've got it here but you can't see it if
you look there's a bizarre i've only
just noticed it actually
i used to be an archaeologist and it
looks to me
like there's a two ring tubeless there
it's an incredible
circular two rings um i think our
our archaeology uh section it's only
looked at this is a desktop
thing i think they need to look at this
because for many years people have
wondered
where why bloody corn is called that
where were the bodies
you don't look at that i mean if it's
there this site is completely out
you cannot build on it it needs looking
at that
the other thing is can i ask the section
106. we've got the draft
terms here and this is something i've
brought up before
and it's past the full council that the
ward members must be consulted
before any section 106 is agreed
[Music]
members haven't been informed yet
because if committee were resolved to
rap commissions there would be subjects
like 106 and then certainly that stage
that would
require the involvement of both members
going forward or
those particular contributions
absolutely well i think they should be
actually consulted even before draft
heads
uh terms of football and there is one
thing about the section 106.
i don't know how many councils have
worked it out but there's another fifty
thousand pounds from mr benjamin
earmarked for the haywood road
roundabout
development and we keep getting this
involved but money keeps getting
put into some pot held by devon county
to do this
those of us who have been to the uh new
development at the end of the bridge
may wonder where that money's going
because the it's absolutely
bizarre complete crackers and i think
this council should query devon county
and say
what is the point of taking money from
developments like this putting it
towards hayward road roundabout
which completely seems to be a complete
waste of money and i like us to look at
that
i know it's not this uh doesn't refer to
this development
solely but um going back to my very
first point i would second
uh thank you councillor christie
anybody else that could contribute
counsel or not yeah i'd just like to
refer back to
a couple of points made by the speakers
in this one i mean i completely refute
what one speaker said to say that
um torridge would have thrown in the
towel if this is approved i do not
absolutely um i refuse that statement
because
every application on its own merits and
the same would
um apply to the world member
when you said it business granted it
opens the floodgates up for other sites
there again it's every application on
its own merits
i'd just like to clear that up um a
couple of positive things
referring again to the 106
and the officers report i think it's the
first time in the officer's report that
we have actually seen a written response
from
nhs i haven't seen that before
no report and i know that they are
making
a contribution to the northern surge in
19
584 pounds and i don't know if anyone
picked up that on the planning portal
the weekly
lists last week there is actually an
application that's been validated for an
extension in all the surgery
so that is a positive um step forward i
think
um right devin county rights away page
110 i mean if this was granted
they ever asked for a condition i cannot
see any conditions
referring to the right of way in the
report
so i just like um a comment on that
please
and with me guard to the um stone
memorial stone
atlantic corner those of us that were
lucky or unlucky enough to be on the
plans committee when we consider the
big nap house development um we've been
through
all this history of um the battlefields
etc etc
and as their own conservation officer
has said
um that development will have less than
substantial whole
harm and the stone is very low
illustrative
and associated values so i'd like to
point that out i just like to comment
please about the rights of weight
conditions should the speaker
um applicant to come in with details for
those resurfacing works and any other
works the public rights away to be
um to be improved and uh submitted to
improvement rights
and that covers it yeah thank you
have you joined all right anybody else
yeah counselor yeah um
i agree i i agree with council a lot
um we've we've been here before with it
and devon county council senior historic
officer has confirmed that there is no
evidence
that this site is the location of the
battle now
i mean until somebody comes up and said
yes this definitely is the site of a
battle
then but for me i i
i can't go along with what some of the
people have said
and so for me
i mean read through this very carefully
i will put forward that we approve it
thank you councillor watson canceled
our thank you
[Music]
key to it is the protection of the
constant estuarine zone
for me on the countryside location
the detrimental impact of the immunity
in the area for people will be huge if
that's developed
and i'm absolutely opposed to this
development
and i can quote and i've got a list of
the mean i can quote why
st 09 coast and s3 strategy
racket 7 development within this area
will be supported
because it cannot be reasonably located
outside this
area well it can we're building
39 dwellings planned for it it could
easily be cited
in the northern area without impacting
on the coast generation
and the countryside so it's contrary to
the stone
we've we've already how many hundreds of
houses
in northern have been granted planning
permission
and are actually being built out present
not just on strategic sites
but on other sites as well
sto-6 strategic and main centers
which includes all northern africa and
west at all
this application lies without the
development boundary
for this area it's contrary to sto-6
little racket's age the avoidance of
development that will contribute to the
coalescence between alcohol and georgia
in other words the loss of yet more
greed space between appledoor and
northern
it's contrary to that policy
st07 spatial development strategy for
northern guns
rural areas little bratic four
in the countryside beyond local centres
villages and rural settlements
this is countryside development will be
limited to that which is enabled
to meet local economic and social needs
and it goes on about rural building
reuse and development
which is necessarily restricted to
countryside location
it's contrary to that course the
nor northern spatial vision and
development strategy
there are strategic sites market for
development within the northern area
development gathering for at least 1736
clearly
we are not sure to development sites
within the development family of
northern range of proposals remained
through the local plan to support the
delivery of the special
spatial vision of the northern area and
it is contrary to that
mppf-170 conserving and enhancing the
natural environment
little steam maintaining the character
of the undeveloped course
this is in the undeveloped course it's
contrary to that
and st 21 managing your delivery of
housing
bracket to its country at b c
and d able to demonstrate in a timely
manner
the addressing of the deficit in housing
supply well
there's no no guarantee of that at all
broadly consistent with not prejudicial
to
contributing towards a positive
achievement of the clan's overall
spatial vision
and strategy for northern devon along
with relevant settlement vision
and development strategy it isn't it
does not support that
and d in all other respects and
importance with other global plant
policies
insofar as they apply it isn't this
conscious visual impact
officer's report concludes the impact of
the proposal the cartridge of
sgo4dmo4 dm08a
and sto
seven st097 seven highways
notwithstanding the highways officer
report the proposal
to use green air control from windmill
then
for access and events to this set is a
recipe for traffic tails
a small cul-de-sac such as green acre
clubs and the days i went again i looked
at it a few times
i went to last night again just to look
at it
it was never designed to take additional
230 plus traffic movements
possible traffic movements a day for
this it'll be
it will require the destruction of a
large part of the hedge pack
to construct the access environment
visibility display
and completely ruin the public right
away footpath
which this road will cross
i just cannot see how anybody could even
recommend this stunt
a very steep road up to windmill and
many of the
objectives to it which are huge numbers
i've
raised this would be unusable in icy
weather
um a bit get a bit of frost on there
they won't go together
i don't and i don't see i do not see
battery-powered mobility scooters
climbing the road very easily windmill
lane is already a very busy and
congested road
particularly in its junction with
churchill away
where a public car park spills out into
the church
traffic coming from the apple direction
at speed it's all right talking about
being in the 30 million
arizona they do come up around that
corner at unfair date
causes a risk when attempting to polite
onto churchill ways
if this site was ever to be developed a
highway connection at bloody corner
was the safest place to apply for access
to it
the nrdm05 highways had
brackets too all development shall
protect and enhance
let's remember the word enhanced
protection enhance existing public
rights of way
listeners footwear cycleways and bridal
ways
and facilitate improvement to existing
or provide new connections to these
routes by practical to do so it's
contrary to that
we've heard about the public right away
officers
holding objection to it at 10
yeah past 10 which runs north to south
of the side
will be completely disrupted by putting
the access rule to it
and as i mentioned you'll have to take a
huge bit of that bangkok
to get the visibility display walking
down there now you walk down a country
footpath with views across this field
right across
the river torridge and beyond it's
fantastic
if this went ahead you'd be walking down
virtually through some of these back
gardens
i think it's absolutely important
on page 32 of the report it concludes
that
flood risk of watershed
drainage the proposal accords with
policies
st 03 and dm04 well we've got no
we are only looking at access to this
stl3
adapting to climate change strengthening
resilience
and dmo4 design principles little end
provide for effective water management
including sustainable drainage systems
water efficiency measures and the reuse
of rainwater
there is no evidence
[Music]
no evidence is provided for this because
we're only looking at the camp line
and we're only looking at access
now when you address this tilted balance
is a misnomer in many ways when you
think about something in balance
and then you tilt it one way or the
other considering issues which may be
considered in favor of the application
as those opposed which mitigate against
the proposal
we have no confirmation that this
application will deliver
any affordable goals of stated we're all
too well aware
that what is promised in outline stages
very often seems to disappear
when a reserve master's application
comes in and
viability appraisals are put forward and
we lose
because of all the other contributions
required
we lose your full environment so we
don't know what this site would import
if this had come forward as a full
application everybody included
importantly the public would have had
all the information
to make a proper decision on this site
if it was a full application
but so much is unanswered in the outline
financial contributions as i've said
almost two hundred thousand pounds
are not guaranteed one or six is only in
draft for top itself
the mention of on-site green space
provision is an insult
when considered against the massive loss
and the wonderful views from footpath 10
and the loss of so much biodiversity the
wildlife corridor this site provides
dotted detrimental impact on the local
highway system
which i much prefer to take the view of
all the residents who live in the area
they have to live with windmill lane and
the traffic
onto church away there and they
as i said at the start 230 plus traffic
movements
from this potential site up that little
cul-de-sac from that concept
it's just ridiculous the future hours in
stock in northern has been hugely
increased
with permissions granted for hundreds of
problems in recent applications
all on designated sites for housing with
others yet to be submitted
but some on other sites have been
limited as well
there's no need to build out into the
countryside and the construction result
so i've listed there why it's contrary
to these
it's contrary to sd09 bracket seven
sto6 brackets h sd07 brackets four
nppf 170 bracket c
sto st 21 brackets two b
c and d d m on five brackets two
and s t o fourteen it is contrary
to all of those and that's it the
recommendation will be refused
anybody else children can it bring in
council wiseman
[Music]
[Music]
a virtual site meeting last week but the
weekend
i went and visited to re-familiarize
myself with these sites as much as
possible um yeah i i
i can't quote you off i'm not going to
quote you a whole bunch of
policies because i think we have to take
it all into
under the light of this one that
councillor christie drew our attention
to on top of
page 26.
but but we've not been able to
demonstrate a five year lap
this is a sustainable site it is boarded
on two sides by development
it's uh walkable from all sorts of
places that people need to get to it's a
there's a bus route there
uh the road through the uh statements
there already is a
far superior to anything that we would
approve nowadays
in width and sight lines of sight and so
forth
i am very much aware of the fact that
it's very controversial this site
however it's sustainable
so we must presume in favor of it i
think i'll have to
i'll have to be in favor of this site
thank you
thank you because i just have that of
course
uh this about this tilted balance
and the fact that we've not got this
five-year housing lancer plan does not
negate all our other planning policies
in our local one so you know it's
what we have to do is to balance the
value of giving this outline permission
for 39 dwellings
in this location against all the other
issues that
i just went through them page after page
thanks for watching
you've just done what in the beginning
when we started this meeting
you said that we weren't going to do is
i we're only looking at access
but you've quoted all the rest of the
stuff which i
i'm not going to go through that that we
shouldn't have been
actually opposing it to we are looking
we're only looking
at the access not not everything else
you know but you've been broke that
counselor council watson can i just tell
you
we're actually looking at giving an
outline planning permission for this
green fighter deciding to call it an
estuary zone with the
country side that will access germany
the only thing to be determined is the
access yes
but we're actually giving if this is
granted planning permission
for 39 dwellings to go on to that side
that's what we're looking at
but the only thing to determine is the
access of all the policies
and this is what we this is what we're
here for
whether the access is fine or not excuse
me excuse me
excuse me i'm speaking
so
what we're looking at all the policies
that i enumerated
and actually running officer mentioned
students through his report
were all applicable to what we discussed
in this morning
[Music]
thank you for stopping by thank you mr
shim um
i'm more than happy to take some of your
additional points to
the motion to refuse application but i
just want to go back to what council
lock and character watson mentioned in
the beginning
but apparently we treat each application
by zone
merit and yet they're discussing
previous applications saying we've been
here before
well i don't agree with that we don't
discuss previous applications i'm not
even aware of this application anyway
so yeah again you know we don't think
we're hard to
my main concern was the residential
immunity democracy being affected
you know it would slide that showed but
the carpark would come into grenade
close
to me
a available important a very important
policy though
and i did say there's no shortage of
science with development in northern
hundreds of hours are being built
currently if nobody else wants to speak
come so long i've seen that we've got
our highways officer uh mr collins here
at the moment
um would it be worth him going through
the
access for us please so we could be
completely sure of it and
sarah mentioned it's been mentioned
about the car park access
i just wondered if mr collins have got
any comments to make on that please from
the highways point of view
well if you have a specific question
any specific question well my specific
question is
um he's withdrawn his objection so he
must be happy
with all aspects of what know what
matters if we can have his confirmation
please
well the chinese report isn't continued
before
have you anything you want to add and i
would just say that
actus is for consideration as you've
been saying
a decision on that needs to be taken in
the light of evidence
that has been provided and there are
there are no recorded collisions
at the junction along that road
no knowledge of any speeding issues
no evidence to suggest that the reason
to refuse the application
could be supported
right thank you thank you right it's
been proposed by council on golf section
i can't sure
just just before we get into the vote
um just a couple things to clarify is
happy
for committing um there's some
discussion about the section 106 and the
obligations that were due
just to confirm that the section 106 is
linked to the outlying planning
permission
uh so they would be secured as per um
the report
um it's not a a possibility
of course there may be a future deal of
variation but that would be sort of a
separate application
so members are considering the
obligations as laid out
in the draft heads of terms secondly in
relation to emotion
emotions performed by counseling
the chair you've um added additional
policies
so i think we just need to clarify
exactly uh what the reason for refusal
is and those policies is that there's
quite a few additional ones that have
been
discussed by the committee since the
original motion
um so just to make speed things
the actual amendment motion was a motion
approval so if we deal with that first
[Music]
um
yeah the second one was for proposing
approved so all i'm thinking is
if that's successful you wouldn't need
to go through what you need to speak
about
but obviously you can do that if it's
not
and just firmly um in the motion
um the tilted balance is engaged um due
to fiber has now supply
whether we like it or not but it's
engaged so
um the chair is absolutely correct um we
can't put weight to the policy of the
local plan despite the five year housing
supply however if um members are mined
to refuse
part of that refusal region should
indicate the waiting that we've been
given
until the balance um so it could be
contrary to members criticized concrete
to
new policies however in addition
comment will need to be made about
materials balance and the weighting of
that
and whether it wants to really outweigh
the benefit
of the proposal
if we'll just go back to something you
said right at the beginning there sean
about
section one and says you said yes they
were being discussed
have counsellor man lee have council of
the ross he was a councillor have they
actually been
part of this discussion because if they
haven't that goes against what we passed
at full council
yes i'll tell you if you wish yes sir
thank you
so as i said we haven't involved the
catch since this stage has dropped it
because it's not drafted yet and not
signed what what we obviously do
in terms of forming an opinion about 106
is a number of consultees make
recommendations to us in terms of the
educational authority etc
sometimes that that there's a
discussion to be had about which how we
go forward with that in terms of
viability as members will be aware and
sometimes we have to think and choose
which
which contributions we prioritize over
others in this case
all of those contributions have been
agreed with the applicant's agent
and so they will automatically go into
the agreement i think
the the one area where where i think
there would be required
particular input is in terms of the
green space contributions
and the need to determine where they
would be applied i.e
existing allotments something like that
or exist in
green spaces it could be enhanced
something like that but i mean if you
take for example the
education contribution the educational
authority has basically said well this
is our this is our shortfall
this is the calculation that we
undertake to
determine what the financial
contribution is
and so then from an officer point of
view that that will just follow through
into the agreement and
we would secure it through that basis
council questions come back on that
because i'm afraid
that isn't acceptable we pass the full
council that all councils will be
involved from the very beginning
and we've just had a planning
application uh come to the town council
only yesterday night where it's at
easter water top of eastern water one of
the section 106s is 75 000 pounds of
benefit state park
which had been queried by the eastern
water council because they weren't
involved in that
and they want it for something that used
to water and i think we must go
we must stick to our own uh rules
if we're going to make any sense of this
well
chad i can come back well yeah quickly
sure yeah
and obviously we're at a position where
um we haven't decided or discussed any
aspects of the 106 so
i think we are in a position where it's
fine we could involve members
um if they were to resolve to grant
permission straight away
um and members are pulling a bit into
how this 106 is drawn
but we are slightly bound as members
wouldn't be aware in terms of the seal
regulations in terms of
regulation one two two which which does
sort of set out what
the criteria to um for contributions to
be acceptable
yeah james i mean the main thing with
this application is
the principle this is what we're looking
at the principle of development of this
site which is in the offices in the
countryside
it's in a designated area coastal
estuarine zone
it's in the undeveloped coast that is
the key
part why we're talking about proposing
to refuse it
this outline that's what we're looking
at all the rest if
it's voted that it's refused you can
forget all the rest of it
because it'd be refused um and
the balance that sean has just again
reminded of us
is does putting 39 houses in that site
outweigh the detrimental impact on the
course of the estrogen
estrogen zone and the uh undeveloped
cost
that's the two that's the balance and
for me
looking through all the other policies
that do apply even
when we use the tilted balance because
of the lack of this five-year anti-gland
supply
even all the other policies are not in
validation
and do contribute in protecting this
side
and that's why i'm strongly in favor
that it's refused
and then we'll go to the vote on the
first application
which can you just mention in your
policy reasons yeah sure mr chairman
mike mcconnell
thank you mr chairman obviously my main
proposal
refuser was is in the undeveloped coast
against the coast and history strategy
sto9
i think it's paris seven that you
mentioned earlier on the residential
immunity
and if you want to at the outside the
development area as well
which is even more key and
adding to that the the tilted balancing
you know 39 dwellings you know
detrimental effect to the area and
i'm happy to quote something all on
themselves just just add a bit more
gravitas to it
so we don't get any legal challenges
come back to us thanks councilman
would you read the moment chairman as i
said
i think what we need to do first of all
is the mulching for approval because
that was put forward second mr
um i've sat in chairs a few times the
first motion
ever gets put to committee is the
emotion you
deal with first you don't deal with the
second one you deal with the first one
to come first
and then the second of our counselor
christie that's not the way i've ever
doubted
you you always deal with the amendment
first and then if that falls then you
come back
[Music]
um i didn't quite get your full reason
there
castlevania mentioned and the uh
policies raised by the chair yeah
which can you just say no yeah sure
obviously i said is that
i'm voting against on the outside
development area yeah
the main one is the undeveloped coast
and against the coast uh s3 strategy
the haunted residential community thank
you thank you lord
and um obviously biodiversity of the
site and
when you said you mentioned that the
tilted advantage want to use terms of
balance
now you know that's as the macho effect
to me
on the resonance so to me
granting the 39 houses it's not
beneficial to the area
and i think the chairman had policies
yeah s29 little brother
that's the one that comes from the
gospel
stl six little brackets h
sto7 brackets four
the mpdf-170 little bracket c
which is to protect this type of assay
s2st21 brackets 2
bc and d
dm05 bracket 2
[Music]
and sdl14h back its age
and i think in the original motion gmo
one community yeah
yes it did yeah i i i wrote down sorry
myself
yeah i wrote down dmo one the
biodiversity my way then i had the sto9
clara seven
and because i think i'm an st 14.
okay that's all right coming to the
vault please
yes thank you chair cancel the bouncer
four that's that's four of you
okay cancer brown
pencil christie four councillor
four councillor mark against councilman
four chancellor watson again councillor
wiseman
yes councillor lanford four
that's six full refusal three against
reviews
yeah just before the next application
our
um so this so this would like to say a
few words
damien i'd just like to hold my hand up
and apologize
uh i'm just getting familiar with your
constitution
and actually the constitution i've been
used to dealing without my previous job
what we would do we would have the
motion put forward
if anybody put forward a counter motion
then we deal with the counter notion
first
but i can see from your constitution
that it's actually going to deal with
the motion that's put
[Music]
more detail foreign sorry about that
thank you damian
right our next application
is on page 39 of your agenda
and tracy tracy blackwell will present
this
we've got two speakers listed and it's
john ford in support
of the applicant and stephen sherry
who's the agent
in fact i'm
okay thank you thank you chair so this
is application
1-0126 2021-4
so um this is a full application for the
demolition of an existing storage
building
and replacement with a production of a
single-story dwelling
um there are no updates i have for
members um
next slide please so this is the
location plan
with the site outlined in red um as you
can see the application site comprises
some parts of land
on the edge of the hamlet name is diddy
well
um i'm aware that we also did a useful
attendance
site inspection last week um so you
should be reasonably familiar with
sites um i say it is located with the
hamlet known as diddy well which is
located within the countryside
next slide this is an aerial image
um so the site has been indicated with
the red arrow
so the image shows the site in
conjunction with the field of movement
southwest and academia to the northeast
uh the site is situated within the
coastal and s rhine zone
um within the undeveloped coast which
i'm sure you're well familiar with from
the previous application
um the site is also within northern
biosphere reserve and also lies in the
triple si impact zone burroughs triple
si
next slide please so this satellite
image is slightly zoomed in
um and really well haven't it so the red
arrow is pointing to the storage
building which is proposed to be
devolved
[Laughter]
is pointing to the storage building
which is supposed to be replaced
um dwelling um just to pick out a few
things in regards to this image
um it is important for members to sort
of note the built form of the hamlet
um the yellow arrow um indicates to
a third-party agricultural yard and
building
um which say is annotated with that
yellow arrow um the site is adjacent to
educational land to the north
side and is bounded by highway to the
east and the south
next slide so this is just an existing
site layout so this shows the two
outbuildings that are currently on the
site and the existing access
which leads onto the site next slide
please
this is the existing elevations of the
storage building
and the workshop building which is
currently on site
next slide so just onto some photos of
the site
so again members should be familiar from
our site in section last week or virtual
site inspection last week
but this is the site access um which
leads into the site from
um from diddy well road next slide
please
again going up to the access which we
walked up virtually last week
next slide these so again the site this
is photos of inside the site
um which we've walked up that existing
access track
and they say you can see the built form
in terms of the houses that are in
really well hamlet
next slide please so we're sort of
in sight now suspected inside the sea as
you can see
um the site comprises of a flat grass
area the site has historically been used
for agricultural purposes however as you
can see
is more akin to a domestic garden area
next slide please
so as i said the site contains two
outbuildings so the breeze block
building to the left
will be demolished to the right there is
a workshop building
and to the left of that you can see a
small lean-to storage building that
would also be demolished
to make way for the erection of the
dwelling
next slide please so this photo is
slightly zoomed in just to give members
a better understanding
of the existing buildings on site and to
show that the breezelock building
will be demolished and that will be
where the position of the
single story dwelling will be erected um
there is just obviously members would
have note from the site inspection that
just
where the fence boundary is to the left
you can just about see
the roof line of the third-party
agricultural building
um in terms of that proximity it's
interesting it's
useful for members just to note that
next slide please so
again this is the agricultural yard
which is
adjacent to the site agricultural
building that is discussed in my report
next slide so going on to the proposal
this is the proposed site plan um
this shows where the proposed swelling
is to be located
as you can see the existing workshop
building needs to be maintained
and the proposed dwelling is to be cited
next to that
next slide please so this is the
proposed elevations of the dwelling
um and also it does show to the right
existing workshop building which is to
be retained
so the dimensions of the dwelling are
approximately 1911.9 metres
and 5.5 meters with a ridge height of
3.82 meters
next slide please and this is the floor
plan
of the or the dwelling um it shows two
bedrooms for non-suite
and then open plans pitching living
lounge area
and a separate store storage in wc
let's slide these
okay so going on to the
material planning considerations this
site is located in the countryside at
the edge of diddy well
a hamlet containing a dozen of houses no
services or community facilities
the site is not well related to the
built form of either northern or
[Music]
the application is being presented as an
open market dwelling to you
supporting statement makes reference to
a live work unit
it is noted that the applicant has a
workshop and you know is well known for
a specialist class
engraving and stained glass work however
there is no justification for this
stained glass workshop to be located
on this site and it is
um i think from his personal statement
he is now steadily retired
and there is no essential need for any
work unit or rural workers
dwelling to be cited here
the supporting statement also indicates
the development will be a self-filled
project
again self-built project
must have called with wider spatial
strategy set out policy st07
and because it's self-filled that
doesn't override any of the other policy
criteria set out in your development
plan
this is not considered to be a
sustainable location the application
site is in the countryside where only
limited forms of development
are considered acceptable it is
acknowledged that canada council cannot
demonstrate a five-year housing land
supply
however the economic and social benefits
of one dwelling is not sufficient to
outweigh
the harm to the countryside and the
unprotected coast
at dwelling presents moving on to visual
impact and landscape character
it is important to note the site is
located within the undeveloped coast
i'm sure members are well-versed in
terms of policy sto9
um but i will read it out again
development will not be supported where
it does not detract from the young
where it does not detract from the
unspoken character appearance of
tranquility in the area
and is required because it cannot be
drawn reasonably located outside the
undeveloped coastal necessary
i don't consider that there is
reasonable justification for this
wedding to be located here
i feel there is other areas where one
dwelling could be located outside of the
undeveloped coast
the applicant wishes to live on on the
site to
continue his specialized glass engraving
business
however this is not an essential need
this is a desire from the acronym
so in the existing site um
on diddy well road i think was pointed
out from the location plan
the existing built form is very much to
the south of diddy well
this will be introducing new development
which is not in accordance with that
built form
and would be a clear departure from the
built form of the hamlet
impact on immunity um there has been
some concerns from the environmental
health
team which is in the report in respect
to how close
the dwelling will be to an established
third-party agricultural use
there has been some complaints from
existing residents in diddy well
i did measure this morning the existing
residents are about 20 meters from that
agricultural yard
this one will be much closer than 20
meters
it is about six to ten meters away so we
are introducing a residential use
where there is some concerns from the
environmental protection team
in respect to that active agricultural
use
and the effect noise of an overdose
would have on future occupiers of the
dwelling
highways so the highway authority have
referred to standing advice procedure
they haven't commented there was a
previous application in
2015 where they have recommended a
visibility display
so i wouldn't necessarily have any
issues for
any concerns on highways in terms of
ecology
natural england haven't made any
comments on the application they have
been consulted and have no comments to
make
submitting ecology concludes that there
isn't any harm to any protected species
or habitats on site
so again i have no issues with ecology
the tilted balance as discussed
the site is located in the open country
side and without without
any defined development boundary the
resident
principal residential environment in
this location would be unacceptable
we have discussed we haven't revived
your housing lands by that tilted
balance does apply
in respect to the overall balancing
exercise while positive aspects of the
proposal are noted
the central aim to our development plan
is to guide open market residential
development towards sustainable
locations that offer a range of services
in addition to this being a countryside
location the site is within the
undeveloped coast
there is no reasoned argument why
dwelling should be located here
additionally there has been concern in
respect to our
offices and the environmental health
facts there will be issues with
introducing
a future proposed west central dwelling
on this site
with an active use of the agricultural
building third party
yard on this basis to consider the
adverse
impacts the granting plan commission
would significantly and dominately
outweigh limited benefits for allowing
one dwelling here
so for that reason it is your office's
recommendation chair or
recommendation of refusal okay tracy
thank you for that
do you need me
[Music]
after it's been sanitized
[Music]
right our first speaker in support of
that
is the applicant mr john ford if you'd
like to come up to the microphone please
yes
and my wife's going to come with me
[Music]
okay okay good morning you've got
three minutes to address the good i've
got one glasses on sorry just give me a
second
[Music]
um
all right mr ford you've got three
minutes to address the committee thank
you
okay yeah first of all i would like to
say that um
i didn't buy the land as an investment
i bought it because i thought we could
work and live there
yeah i've worked all my life in glass
and um
although i'm semi-retired um i'm still
very busy
and i don't intend to stop until
somebody upstairs says it's the end of
the day really for me you know
um and i've always had a workshop um i
lived in dinner for four years
i worked in diddy world 40 years
and i'm very bad at this because i'm
dyslexic but we've blamed it you're
right i'm sorry if i'm a bit slow yeah
i lived in d where 40 years ago and was
born in torrington
um i studied stained glass under james
patterson of benefit school of art
um after that i joined swordsman
cathedral restoration team
and uh latin after that i
returned to devon and four years later
i started my workshop give you one my
first workshop which i built
i had a courtesy and my son was born
known
um i also worked at darting and crystal
that time and latterly became a designer
for them
the opportunity came for me to go to
sweden and pursue
my long-term interest which was making a
class called growl glass which involves
making pictures on glass
okay um and which brought me some
international recognition i hate saying
that but it did okay
um um okay the majority of my work is
based
on com and now and majority of my work
is based on commissions restoring
stained glass
and painted stained glass windows
i've owned the land for seven years we
cleared the land prepared the buildings
and planted a native hedgerow
what we want to do now is replace an old
piggery building
which i must admit to anybody is pretty
ugly yeah
um for a small modest
place for us both to work new
i feel our plans are modest with low
impact
in our opinion they have empathy with
the surrounding agricultural lab
in our opinion the building would
improve the state
and be an enhancement to to a hamlet
which we love
four or five four out of five of our
nearest neighbors
have supported our application and the
planning offices report acknowledges
that the building would not be intrusive
to anyone else
in the neighborhood sustainability
i don't understand the word but here we
go yeah the road
trip the road trip from my flat where
i'm living at the moment which is rented
to the workshop is five miles sometimes
i do that twice a day our life would
would be less environmental cost if if
we didn't have to do that
i mean environmental impact basically
and we could do with one calf
the site at the site is 15 minutes walk
from the center of northern
which i feel is sustainable and five
minutes walk to the top of the road in
primrose lane from the bus stop to apple
door
paper yeah can i actually find it
i'm sorry okay i've got a little bit
more i'm
two paragraphs okay yeah we've been on
the torridge tdc cellphone register for
five years with no offers of a plot
from tdc or anywhere else my opinion our
opinion is a perfect
self-build site in our opinion and the
money for the software would stay in the
area
okay okay the planning authority officer
is very concerned about the sheep
i have no problem with the sheep it's an
agricultural community
okay sum up nice sorry about that host
prices have escalated far away from us
at the moment and an alarming rate i'm a
local guy
i was born here i only want to build a
very small
modest two-bedroom single-story house
and continue the work that i've done
all my life thanks very much and thank
you for your time and i hope you can
support her thank you mr ford
thank you if you'd like to
take a cheap breath if you don't mind
please thanks a lot
[Music]
right now our next speaker on this
application in support of the
applications
the agent mr steven sherry
[Music]
there's constant reference to the site
being in open countryside
whereas i believe it is in the
countryside there is a legal
difference isolated dwellings in the
countryside are open can decidedly
decide in recent high court cases
so it is in the countryside rather than
open country side it's a subtle
difference but that's what
it is the officer does say the site is
akin to a domestic garden
and it does look like that in the photos
it just needs a
house there and the planning officer
does agree that building won't have
impact on views or amenities of other
residents
it's behind a big hedge rose mr ford has
planted
there's an existing sewer right behind
the site
and all the services are all there ready
one thing that's been made much play off
is environmental health
and the adjacent agricultural building
uh that building is only used twice a
year for lambing and sharing
in fact i looked up the planning
commission which was only granted in
2015
and it has a condition in condition
three that specifically states that the
building is not to be used for livestock
so that is a bit of a red herring
in terms of uh precedence i mean uh
i'm sure some people have seen that uh
there's a site for ten houses
off tide road in appledore that started
construction
very recently it's in the same coastal
preservation area that was justified and
we feel houses as well
mr ford mentioned that he will save on
car journeys
um a bit of working out quite
quickly showed that just by living on
site you'll save half a ton
of carbon dioxide equivalent each and
every year
that's without reducing from two to one
cars so
it does it will make a difference on
conservation
the running size is very small it's 65
square meters
it's the same size as a two-bedroom flat
on the affordable scale
it's not a big property they're looking
to build he's already
mentioned that faculty's been on the
housing self build this for five years
and nothing really happens with it
the policies in the local plan were
formulated
nearly a decade ago and didn't really
reflect
self-build properties
but working from home i just mentioned
statutory council teas
at denver county council obviously
they're fine with it
natural england big one there they've
confirmed very recently that no comments
to make on this application
that's important given what the officer
said
and of course northern town council have
recommended
an approval they haven't said no
comments they've recommended approval
there's many good reasons to approve
this application toys don't have a
five-year housing supply therefore it's
a presumption in favor of development
more importantly mr and mrs ford are in
rented flat
it's a great opportunity for them to
have a lift work dwelling
that would be a self-filled
although they're probably i've been
unkind to my client
probably the oldest first-time buyers
before you they are a good local working
couple
and want a very modest proposal we
welcome your support
thank you thank you mr sherry
our final speakers
our final speaker is councillor ford
who's board member
yeah i'm i'm not willing to touch
greatly
on the policies because you know again
that they are
to be interpreted as you see fit
um however just along the way biosphere
triple s i l a n o b etcetera it seems
that
we're okay with every damn uh jet ski in
that area
an area of wildlife and now you're
worried about a tin top two bedroom
bungalow on a more serious note however
it's been brought to my attention of the
applicant and several other people that
one control
committee is rather friendly with
the only objector i would call on that
person to not take part because
in that position i wouldn't myself
that's just for clarity and that has
been brought to my attention
so just give it due consideration i
would not have bought it here
if this was a trustpage 40 i couldn't
support it
but it is modest he's not trying to pull
a fast one here like we've seen in the
past and if he actually come back
and try to make it double the size he
wouldn't get my support
so just give it a fair graphic just for
you know
if i do notice the next application i'll
watch a value vote on this one
and i'll compare it to the next one
thank you
thank you counselor
that concludes the speakers to this
application um
we would like to start with this
but well i'm gonna have a couple of rows
cancel a lot
have you got a comparison to what the
height is of the
existing building that will be
demolished please just for comparison
yeah the proposed way will be higher
sorry the proposed wedding will be
higher than the existing building
by how much did you know um
yeah so it will be slightly higher than
that probably by about a meter
yeah um so yeah so so it will be
obviously in terms of eating building
rent and building boundaries that height
obviously comes from that
um and obviously the existing storage
building can't be converted because
it it's not high enough but it's not
i guess structurally sound enough to
convert it to as well so it has to be
demolished but yes
to answer your question i could say
about about approximately that means
higher than the existing building on
site
yeah another buy on sustainability um i
was going to bring it up but the
uh one of the first speakers said that
um
at the moment he lives away from the
site and he may drive to the site three
or four times a day whereas if he lived
on site
and that would definitely cut down all
his car journeys and carbon emissions so
that's a plus for the application
um and also i mean it is so close to
lots of other facilities in the area so
i do think that it is a sustainable site
uh my one concern is i mean it's quoted
as a live work unit
um would it be tied to the work unit
or would it be an over market house i
mean would there be a way of saying
could we tie it to his business so it's
being presented as an open market
dwelling to you
um there is reference to the supporting
statement of rural work dwelling war on
the work unit
so policy dm 28 would then need to
apply they don't meet the functional
needs to be living on site
there is no need for the workshop to be
in that reward location and there's no
need for
in terms of man hours you know we
haven't got those financial people
mentioned before about the financial
figures we haven't got that in front of
us
i very very much doubt it will meet on
cdm28
because they haven't got man hours to
actually be
needing to be justified to be living on
site day and night
and also one final point with regard to
the
use of the shed for sheep and the
feeding area
i mean you've quoted that um the houses
the 20 meters
on the other side of the road they're 20
meters apart but if this dude running
was grounded it would only be between 6
and 10
but the new dwelling would have a fence
up between
them and the agricultural shed whereas
the
um houses on the opposite side and did
you although
they look straight onto it they've got
no means of blocking the smell on the
view
i wish yeah i appreciate that i think
what i'm sort of saying to you is that
obviously that it would be a lot nearer
there this is
essentially agricultural land and we're
introducing residential development onto
a site that's for agriculture
um i appreciate there is a fence but
obviously the environmental protection
team has to raise concerns
over um so you know in terms of odor
in terms of that rising i'm not sure
that boundary fence are not uncertainty
and the environmental health officer
wasn't happy that the boundary bent
would mitigate any smells
from that agricultural yard being used
and if you can see from the photo
you know someone has mentioned it's only
been twice
twice twice a year being used but
when i've arrived driven by i have seen
she's in there and obviously the yard
i mean there is a lot of mud and manure
on that on that yard so it is obviously
frequently used
um as i say you have concern from your
environmental protection team
and that forms part of that harm that
i'm putting forward to you
thank you thank you jeff thank you
council a lot
um of course this site's quite a bit
higher than the yard next to
where the as we saw from the photographs
uh that's up on the right behind that
sentences
difference in height um can i just ask
the planning manager
can if this was to be granted can we
remove
the
[Music]
to be used in conjunction
um i think that would be difficult to do
that because what's being applied for
is a market wedding and this comes into
council locks comments
about the carbon saving
you are looking at it as an open market
dwelling so whilst we appreciate
what we have been stating it could be so
tomorrow somebody
who works elsewhere so it's not
restricted
and can we restrict any possible
development in the restaurants
future sheds and outside any other
building yeah
okay just so um who else would like to
comment on this
yours area in active use which could
present problems
in terms of noise coder and why nuisance
receiver but actually this
this applicant actually is already there
most of the day
and nothing will be used to any smells
noise or odor
it might come from there so i would um
i would think you know this application
might be approved
of course the of course the tilted
balance comes into play again
this side is with the previous one and
you've got to look at the whale what's
applied for on this side
the harm the sustainable development of
the site for this
the effect it might have on the
surrounding area well i think we
saw from all the photographs and i know
the site well as i travel down
onto the onto the barrels every morning
i pass it sometimes
that you can't see the size it's almost
[Music]
history that there was a previous
application that has been refused on
this site back in 26 or 2015 i believe
it was
members should be aware that that
patient did go to appeal
um and those who was in 2016
clearly in relation to the previous
young man not becoming a doctor
not innovation by the housing land
supply however the inspector did say
that he included that the proposal would
not amount to a sustainable form of
development
and it would conflict with relevant
aspects of local national policy
and he also raised concerns with the
impact on uh
dental landscape
so disciplines or whatever
right yeah
follow those comments from um and then
the appeal was in february 2016
was the applicant already using his
workshop in 2016.
i don't have recommendations
reference to the engraving business and
brain business on the site
on indian peer decision so i i believe
yes the inspector was aware that there
was an engraving business on that site
being run
okay i mean i do take the point
exactly where it is in this little
homeless you did it
[Music]
the argument that it's not a sustainable
site but i don't
it obviously is you can you can walk
and as the applicant said primrose lanes
just up there
in your own area where they see the lane
going up to the right
um and you're at the bus stop at the top
so it's not that far away you could
cycle
to and from this side easily i do take a
point
about having to drive in by calm down
maybe a couple of times or more a day
and there would be a saving there i mean
i have to say looking at it when i
looked at it the other day sorry
we oh sorry i have to say when i looked
at it in the day
and uh after we had the site visit last
week
and i was looking at in detail i really
couldn't see why we couldn't allow
such a modest little two-bed place on
here
as a self build i mean the applicant
states has been
trying to get a site for about five
years for himself though
he's got this site with what he's got
his
last workshop and i really
am struggling uh to find some reason
to refuse this to be
question yeah i totally agree with you
um i don't agree that that it is not
sustainable
to be quite honest uh but i think it is
and after the comments that
um about just traveling
there in batman three or four times a
day
the carbon saved for a year
etc i'm struggling to find a reason
to refuse this so
yeah i'll leave it to somebody else
everybody else
well i'm i'm i'd like to i'd like to be
able to approve this to be honest i
really
yeah are you proposing it i'll
um
um i think the main reason
is that it's a self-built project
it's terrible danny
just saying that uh
for me it's a self-built scheme i think
we should be supporting people who want
to
engage in self-built schemes of a modest
so this is a very modest
uh application and the thing is it does
not detract from the area of diddy well
there's quite a few dwellings in diddy
well in some quite new ones
and just down the lane only just down
the lane on the other side
um an elderly residence dwelling was
committed a couple of three years ago
i think members were on the committee
they don't remember that
yeah so there has been development in
the area
it would not detract from the area in my
view in any way
and it will give take somebody out of a
rented accommodation
into a self-built modest property and
enable them to little work on the site
which i think is the kind of thing that
this council choice
i suppose no detriment to the estuary
it's not at all to the uh close to the
estrogen
and for those reasons that it is why i'd
yeah i would comment that your officers
have um obviously recommended refusal
and there are reasons for refusing the
committee report
so i i hear the members struggling for
just refusing but the office of
professional viewers should be with
the reasons i still have concerns
about the um weight given by committee
members in relation to
somebody living on the site who's
working on the site and i say is that of
the market dwelling
i wanted to be able to be so the next
day um
just somebody who doesn't live on the
site so it might be minimum wages
[Music]
he did mention that because it's been
advertised and don't
market dwelling it could be so many
minutes it's put there it could be sold
to any
well it could be but i think restrictive
taking away the permitted development
rights of that site
are really going to hem it in you know
and i just think it is the kind of
scheme that this committee ought to be
supporting
and i do take notice that on the tilted
balance and we haven't got
i mean m a we're struggling for
affordable loans in the area
and on the tilting balance looking at
that we haven't got this lack of land to
put one small
modest development in there and it's
only single story
looks like an agricultural building from
the drawings i've got to draw it
we've seen them on stream and for that
reason i think
that this committee can be better so
it's been recommended for approval by me
secondly by councilwoman
with the conditions mentioned that
shawn's mentioned and the visibility's
clearly did
cancel a lot yeah can i just say then
the npdpf on rural house
number 77 in rural areas planning
policies
and decisions should be responsive to
local circumstances
thank you for that and that is that is
mvpf rural housing number 77
and i think by you know if we did
approve this we would be
being responsive to local circumstances
yeah thank you councilman thank you for
that
right it's been months that we grant
this excellent
yes thank you chair thank you very much
councillor brown councilor christine or
councillor four chancellor four
captain the girl four chancellor watson
oh
[Music]
thank you
thank you
is application 6 and debbie
is going to present this application
okay so um this is for an outline
application with all matters reserved
right one local needs dwelling land at
home
otherwise known as bradford hall square
new devon
i've got a verbal update two viral
updates so
uh the percolation test is a reasonable
refusal
uh number two the calculation tests
hadn't been submitted at the time they
have been submitted this morning
um i haven't had time to
uh speak to environmental protection
about whether they're okay but
the surface water drainage has been
submitted
and that shows that that's sufficient
so a soak away from a um
packaged treatment plant apparently will
be at a higher level
and um than that required for surface
water and there's
sufficient land the applicant owns
so drainage eric could be provided so
you might want to consider removing
the refusal number two
uh so yeah next slide please
so this shows the location uh of
otherwise known as bradford um in
context the torridge uh this is the site
so the site is in
red and the land owned by the
applications in the gloom
check could i just ask a question tom
can you expand that a bit
sure can you oh yeah
yeah so you can see the proximity to the
holes
so it's it's within a group of
um the parish of bradford and quickly
you've got please support up here
brandeis corner cook green quickly with
a number of settlements in that area
from next slide please
um so yeah this is an indication of
where
the um the farm that the applicant works
out in to the north that's about
400 meters from the site
and in yellow that's the village hall
and primary school about
700 meters on the site
and you can see um the settlement built
area
of homework just to the north so the
site is about 100 meters from the built
um
so these photos show um the lane to the
south
so there's a country lane runs to the
south and then it goes up
to the um settlement itself
on the eastern boundary there's some
stables
with access and across the road from
there
are a few small agricultural buildings
but the nearest built form is about 100
meters from the site
next slide so the two
planning considerations is in detail in
your
report but um
in terms of because it's an outline
we're not considering layout
design and access today
but there is an assessment now for
character and appearance
residential immunity highway
considerations ecology and drainage
um the principle it doesn't qualify
as a rule settlement and local needs
dwellings are specifically allowed in
rural settlements so
um in the report this definition of
rural assessment
which i'm sure well um
and as you know the local authority
cannot demonstrate five year supply
so uh i've had to undertake the
planning the tilted balance and look at
the pros and cons
in terms of sustainability so section
eight of your report outlines
all of this and um as i say
it doesn't qualify as a settlement which
is why i'm recommending
refusal whether there's on balance
there's also
um concerns about the site
being an intrusion into the rural area
it's not
a joint form and due to its location
there'd be a reliance on private
transport and
[Music]
sustainable travel in terms of walking
and cycling
um is unlikely there's no footpaths
it's not lit um
they're very narrow there's hardly any
particle places
in that location so um
overall my view is that
the adverse impacts outweigh any
benefits
and my recommendation would be to refuse
the application
but you might want to consider taking
off lisa for refusal
too because as i say i've had details
about very much
this morning
thanks um thank you very much
if you'd like to vacate that moment
never can have the speakers
[Music]
we've got we've got three we've got
three speakers
left the first one is john snail
on behalf of the parish aren't you a
parish council
yes welcome
thank you you've got three minutes to
address your community thank you
yes thank you hello my name is john
smale
i'm representing bradford and cuthberty
paris council
bradford and cookery are very rural
communities with agriculture being the
prime
economy of both parishes as a parish
councillor we wish
to support bradley and amnes application
as we try to support valid applications
from the younger generation we believe
it is essential for the future and
vitality of bradford and cookery
parishes
to have younger families living and
working here
bradley who works on his family farm
which is a large and progressive farm
where farming is the main income of all
the families involved
and covers a large part of both parishes
he is the fifth generation of a farming
family who have always
actively contributed to many aspects of
our community
this is a very important part of the
social and economic structure
of our area they have a young family who
would like to attend our village farmers
school
and at present abby has started a baby
and toddler group
our school is very well resourced but we
need young families in the parish to
keep it viable
a school plays a huge part to keep rural
parishes alive
which is another reason we feel strongly
about supporting this application
bradley his father grandfather and great
grandfather
all attended bradford primary school so
to conclude
this application is more than just a
house to live in it is part of what
keeps our very rural community alive
thank you thank you council ismail
uh the next speaker in support was sent
in a statement
debbie newcombe was sent in the
statement which
thank you councillors for allowing me to
speak today the application before you
is for local needs dwelling
a more genuine case would be difficult
to find
as you are aware the demand for housing
in the area is ever increasing
and will be increasing from home
becoming more prevalent
and many from cities moving to this area
house prices are rocketing
and making what was already a difficult
issue for local people to get onto the
housing market
is now almost impossible in summary of
the report submitted with the
application
the applicant mr oak and his family
currently live in a static caravan on
his parents lawn
he owns the land the subject of this
application which gives him an ideal
site to build his family home
at least four generations of his family
have owned and worked on the farm
which is 400 metres to the north his
partner
runs a baby group at the school has been
asked to run a preschool
this together of them having two young
children all contributes to
sustainability of the local school
a short distance from the site there's
so many real schools shutting due to
dwindling numbers
the opportunities the school is engaging
will ensure that it is kept open
they are involved in many community
events that are held at the community
hall
even by organizing or attending again
contributing towards a healthy village
environment
given that mr works on the nearby farm
you may ask
why we are not seeking permission for
rural workers dwelling
the answer is that there is no suitable
position on the farm for new dwelling
the applicant does not own land on the
farm and so the best solution is to
build a land he owns
this however would not meet the rural
workers policy of being well related to
the farmer's debt
we are therefore applying for permission
in line with policy dm-24 of the local
plan
to pick up a few points in your office's
report the mdpf
emphasizes that sustainable development
in rural areas
housing should be located in existing
settlements that will enhance or
maintain the vitality of rural
communities
homeward is a settlement of
approximately 30 hours
the proposal cannot be considered as an
isolated home countryside
the school and community hall are both
located a short distance from the site
this site is no different to sites
approved in daryl for norfolk dwellings
where there are no community facilities
to make it a rural settlement
global has much more in terms of
community facilities
the application has made an outline to
gaining principle development
given the applicant's need a reserved
matters application will be submitted
within the next few months
and its deliverability will be carried
out in a timely manner
the first recommended refusal reason
advising on the site is isolated
as can be seen from the site plan it is
well related to other buildings and
assessments
the reason goes on that the applicants
will be relying on private transport for
day-to-day living and employment
this may be the case however these will
be primarily short distance
distances which will sail over 400
meters away at the farm
which is easily walkable and is part of
working 600 meters away in the school
a travel distance of under about a day
is less than people living in town or
travel
this is unlikely to change given the
young ages of children who are both
under two
at the time they need to move to
secondary school and it's assumed that
they
would be support school transport the
increase in supermarket home delivery
services
would also contribute to reduction in
any need to travel
and is therefore considered that this
reason is unreasonable
the applicant requests they consider his
case and approve this as a local needs
following
implying the conditions you feel
appropriate
thank you a final speaker
for this application board member cancer
james
[Music]
so thank you well i i
looked into this one and why um it was
up for approval
i looked back at when my daughter got a
local need
25 years ago and it came under
the 97 2011. local plan
which is quite specific that homo is a
schedule b village and therefore it
would qualify
for and it says seeks to address
local social and economic needs so
that that is how the policy was and it
also identifies in schedule b
that it will be limited to what is
essential
to meet identifiable local social media
and economic needs
so that is it and that's all it was in
the
the new plan i've got to admit it is a
bit more vague and i have to
wonder why we've ended up with the local
plan we have
but that's how we are the site itself
the highways agreed that that complies
with the entrance will comply with dm05
dm06 and is considered acceptable the
postulation test
percolation tests have been submitted um
i did have a phone call very late last
night to say that they're going to mix
up and they would be getting the stuff
in this morning
and they gradually the applicant had to
come back from cyanogen to sort it all
out last night
so they didn't go down very well but i'm
sure that that will all be okay
there's plenty of area there it's free
draining wound and there was also a
stream running by
so the new circulation would actually be
able to go into that
the reason for this being local need
well as you just heard um there is an
issue with building any more actually on
the farm
but i think when it says in the report
that it won't have to
um housing stock of course builder
will need one will because that will be
local needs for perturbity
and that would mean that for any reason
the applicant stopped working on the
farm
um he could carry on living there with
his family or
conversely if when he need he needed to
move the dwelling would be available for
another local family
to move into so dwelling
if this there was some um discussion
about whether the site the dwelling
should be lower in the field
nearer the other properties but the
field is much higher the buildings below
are actually built down into the field
so they would be looking straight into
the windows and also if
you remember the plan um earlier on
from the barn conversion downwards the
land doesn't give access
to the that field belongs to other
properties so that is an
ideal it would be the only entrance so
if you didn't build the bundle then you
built it lower down
and you would overlook the hoses and b
you would still have to build the
entrance back up where the entrance is
proposed to be
so um and it's rather interesting being
an isolated site
in the environmental protection
officer's report he asked for
construction control measures to ensure
that it doesn't effect on um neighboring
dwellings close proximity ones
right in in relationship to local
facilities the parish hall
and those who know about how short it's
probably one of the best in rural areas
it is all built by the locals by raising
money
um it's right next to go to the school
the school
is a terrific school it's probably half
as big again as the bridgeway one
and it's got half as many pupils
um and i can remember many years ago
taking our point in school children
they've played football
and to do the sports say that so it is a
regarded as a hub for the world area
hansel hepburn and myself were invited
there in 2019
by the head of the what was then not the
academy but it was the
anyway we went there because they were
concerned about the 40 numbers
they wanted to engage the local coasters
in
what could be done to enable more
children to live in the area
to keep the school going so we actually
went there and we're showing around the
school
um and it's a trivia school it's a very
large playing area
it's got a specific play park which most
schools don't have
and as they say they can take about 80
and there's less than half in school at
the moment
and as we know with villages and so many
schools are closing
um the family itself well you've heard
it all
um abby the mum she's started up her
mum and baby club in school with working
with the head teacher
and i was actually in ritual school
yesterday morning
where we're doing some work on providing
a cycle area for the children
and we did discuss this and the head
teacher said oh please she was that
they've got
a mother and baby club going out at that
school to try and secure its future
um so i won't go through all of it so
basically in summing up as far as i'm
concerned yesterday it's the old policy
but it complies completely with 97 2011
which i would assume we ought to be
using in the new local plan
that's um sorry it's easy to reach for
the school in the village
you know any law school um it's always
arguably about walking to but it's a
very quiet road
and it's it's not unwalkable um so
i think that's a fair comment on that it
will keep the village and the school
alive
and it provides a home for a family
that's been there if you've heard four
generations
and it is hope there will be more
generations to come
so to me is i'm not gonna say no
but to me is what we should be looking
at in the community
is providing the home for the locals
that live in that area
and we keep the school going we keep the
whole
ethos of the area going so thank you
very much
thank you councillor james thank you
right that concludes the speakers for
this application
is whether the parish is meant to be the
rural settlements well i mean if
you know that is unclear for starters
i think that needs some clarification um
so i don't know if the officer can
explain that comment it is unclear
whether the parish is meant to be the
rural settlement
either it is or it isn't
sorry council locket is meant i miss
that last bit is meant for
what did you say about the parish
council all right
i didn't hear what you said about the
parish council no i didn't
i said it's unclear whether the parish
is meant to be the rural settlement
it's on bottom of the page sixty-one
january
not the paris council the actual parish
yeah sorry um i guess the point was that
um the agent has said that he's lived in
the parish his whole life
but i wasn't sure whether that was the
rule settlement because the criteria
is um at least one adult in the
household
in continuous employment for 16 hours in
liberal assessment for at least five
years
but that's being confirmed that yeah he
works on farm whole farm
which is well is it in the raw
settlement i guess that's
the question yeah it's 400 meters
outside of the built form but there's no
settlement boundary
so that doesn't work in the normal
are approximately 700 meters away but
that is
less than our other moment i mean many
people lived in larger settlements and
towns would love to live that close
and even then they would probably hop on
the bus or drive their car
so i just cannot believe that you know
um you consider it to be unsustainable
and you know the poor highway network
comprised of narrow country lanes
that is all part of rural life and i
know i represent a really rural area
but if you live in a rural area that is
what you expect
narrow country lanes which are
sustainable um
the one problem i do have with this
application is
the field is one hectare in total but
the area chosen for the development is
only 0.1 of a hectare
if the application was granted would the
permitted development rights be removed
on the best of the field
so that it doesn't open up a can of
worms for future applications
um members could remove christopher
wright's the area read on the plan in
front of you
now committed to development in relation
to the domestic dwelling
that was being committed um so it
wouldn't stop any future applications
coming in on the rest of the land that i
flew on the planet
that would restrict things like sheds in
domestic
buildings within that red outline
right so that the applicant only owns
that one particular field
which is very very close to the rest of
the farm so
i would question if is that of thriving
business
why the business have support um has
submitted an application
for agricultural workers wedding even if
it is on the applicant's
field because you can apply the planning
permission on anyone's land if you would
issue a certificate being so i just
wondered
why the farming business hasn't applied
for agricultural workers doing it
which would fit in with more policies
you don't know that no the agent has
confirmed there's no land on the farm
available for him
yes but yeah yeah the farm could apply
on this field
and issue a certificate b yeah yeah
um just to go back and cancel whatever i
made yeah
uh in this statement i just read out
from the applicant's agent
it does touch on that point um and it
says
um the applicant does not only land at
the farm which we just discussed
um however a real worker's their view is
that
the real workers policy wouldn't be
relevant to this piece of land because
it's not well related to the farmstead
uh so it wouldn't record the development
policy uh was a view of the agent
well i thought it was only 400 meters
away from the farm
clearly your officers haven't considered
this as a real workers dwelling all
those policies
there'd have to be a requirement as well
um
a labour requirement you know they have
to prove that if it was an agricultural
worker swelling
um i don't know all the detail but
it might be that there is only a
requirement for
the person
i'm in favor of this application though
i would recommend
approval that it fits with dm05 and dmo6
and the mppf 7778
i'm drawn to this because this is a
similar situation where i live
and and as you know that i think people
have got three more hours than what
we've got in our village
i think it was quoted there's only 20 20
hours here
and 17 with deca but we we are looking
to build
17 to 20 houses in our village
which is in the local planet and
i really i really do support this um
it is sustainable
i wish our village had cut and got a
school
which he used to have but it was closed
um et cetera and and yeah i'll support
this and i agree with the
with what council lot says but i would
also say that it does fit the m24
that my proposal would be subject to
committed development rights
yeah of course permitting development
rights would only
be in the red line side yeah
um anybody anybody else want to speak
well
i'll speak when i first saw this i just
don't understand
why anybody would stick a dwelling out
in the corner of a large field like
it sticks right out like a sore thumb
pulley why it wasn't
sighted at the top end there near the
rest of the glans i don't know
there is a route there is a route to get
and hopeful work is dwelling probably
for a key worker for the farm and they
don't use that bruise and i
i don't know why they haven't um but
we've got to deal with what's in front
of us
and it's just an isolated dwelling
in the countryside i can't see any
i really have a job to find any reason
to um to not go with the refusal i mean
i think refusal standards for very good
reasons
there is a room picking up from what the
board members said there is a route if
you want
and it's been mentioned by council a lot
that was arrested
if this is a key agricultural water then
the farm can apply
on any piece of land close by if the
landowner permits it
to put in agriculture what is learning
and they've not done that
matter i don't know why
it does stick out like a small thumbnail
the other thing is it's
so next door certain stables in that
little right next door
on the right of it there is stables and
that could have been
a detrimental impact to anybody living
in a dwelling in that location
um i i can't uh
i can't go along with that approved
because
anybody else up principle can we put an
agricultural restriction on it as well
just to
doesn't that all i'm just concerned
about is that it doesn't get sold on the
open market
you know that it has to sort of stay
within you know local needs effectively
or if it had an agricultural restriction
then that would that helpful isn't that
possible within this
i don't know sure yeah if i may chair um
it's not been the application isn't in
relation to that cultural wellness
dwelling
uh so it wouldn't be reasonable to an
occupancy condition tying it
um to a cultural worker it has been
applied for as a local needs dwelling
and our local needs policy
is dm24 which offers support for local
needs dwellings
when they're in rural settlements uh as
you've seen from the officer's report
our view is that the actual site here
isn't really
a real settlement for reasons outlined
with the report
however i haven't stated that cm24 does
outline how we deal with local needs to
alex
and how we secure those in the future
and there are certain criteria that we
want to secure from the future if
there's a local needs dwelling
which is outlined in 13.133 of a local
plan
um that will be secured via section 106
agreement
ordinarily as opposed to condition in
terms of secure mechanism
moving forward which will retain it as a
little knees dwelling
there are certain criteria that anybody
who's
wanting to live in that dwelling would
have to meet
and i can read those out if it's helpful
committed members of this stage so they
know
what they're looking at that will be
helpful
yeah so so this is articulated in
paragraph 13.133
in terms of local needs i say it's real
settlement so this is slightly different
but so
new dwellings will be allowed subject to
secure arrangements
to ensure occupancy is limited both
initially and in the future
too one at least one adult in the
household was
resident continuously in the rural
settlement for a minimum of five years
immediately prior to occupation or two
at least one adult of the household was
resident and assessment for five years
within the previous ten years
immediately prior to occupation
or three at least one parent guardian
child or sibling
of at least one adult in an attended
household has been resident in the rural
settlement for a minimum of five years
immediately prior to occupation or
four at least one adult in the household
has been in continuous employment for at
least 16 hours per week
in the real settlement for at least five
years immediately tried the population
and in all cases five at least one adult
in the household
needs a separate home defined as though
setting up a new household as
a cohabitation marriage divorce
separation
all those that have or about to leave
tight accommodation on retirement
or whose present accommodation is
substandard or unsuitable for the
present circumstances
because of their age and impairment
medical condition
or meet the needs of a growing family or
there's no suitable accommodation
available now given the information
provided in the application i understand
the applicant
is living in a static care and a mobile
home
so it would appear that they would
qualify under those five criteria
what i would state though is that those
criteria does refer to a real settlement
and it's clear to your officers that
this isn't a real settlement
so members may wish to change that
phrasing real assessment to
perish which would then keep it a little
need flat parish
and that may be something that members
wish to discuss further
as well as the section 106 agreement
there are
quite a few conditions that you may want
advice from your officers
before preparing a motion if emotions
want to
approve and we can provide a device in
those conditions if required
thank you for that very comprehensive
is
[Music]
yeah we can discuss conditions now and
um carry the motion
and then if the section 106 wasn't
assigned we can bring it back to
committee
and if it was signed then it would
character that's very much
captured so what you're saying is the
word
parish needs to be defined and take
priority
a parish is defined rural settlement is
defined in the local plan
but this location isn't clarified as a
real assessment as it's defined
in the ban so we wouldn't be able to use
real sentiment in that wording
section 106 because it's not technically
in the real assessment
this real assessment
you need to ch we need to change this to
parish then yeah
and that way foreign
so instead of yeah so the parish then
we're talking about
this being in the parish
this is
subject reception one or
just getting some advice
if this was to be it's been moved to
but if it's moved to approve that and
we've got this section
offsets what are these are the
conditions then if it's if it's
apparent it's going to determine it's in
the parish
okay so um condition wise it is a
outline application
so members was to look at the standard
condition requiring the reserve matters
applications to be submitted
yeah um members should also be looking
at the
uh time standard time condition uh to
ensure that um
the implantation is built out um
[Music]
members have made mistakes there's a
structural management plan
which would indicate house construction
etc um
given the comments from the
environmental protection officer about
impact on immunity
[Music]
i would also suggest that there's a
condition requiring details of drainage
um both bowel and surface water drainage
you've heard the comments from the
officer about population tests
but we also want to have detailed design
of that um
to secure and
um have a lot probably mentioned about
removal committed development rights as
well so that may also work for condition
[Music]
and also construction hours which is
like outside the environment
section of certain medicines and again
we can calculate the wording with
introduction chair vice chair if that's
appropriate to do so
that's fine right
i've never heard this changed about in
this way there
to be a parish rather than settlements
i've never i've never heard an
application being changed
to define it as being in a parish rather
than a settlement
i thought that was only in respect to
the 106 supreme
the affordable housing needs that's
related to the parish yeah so it's only
in relation to the 106. yeah
so it restricts the obviously that in
the future
and the only reason we'd be doing that
is because we're stating that this
isn't a real assessment um
members could have a view that is within
a real settlement but the
term's real assessment is defined and
there's concerns about that moving
forward
because if it was a settlement there
were very few people there
possibly want to take it if if the
occupiers left so it's better that it
goes out to the parish
anyway oh yeah you know i mean we've got
this situated
in old worthy ambulance well i built the
to
outside
and and that that is just the same
right well if nobody else wants to
contribute to this
it's been moved by councilman send it
back out to the watson
to move to approval of this
subject to the section 106 defining that
this is
an affordable what's the word it's a low
police dwelling in the parish
yeah that's fine bradford that's it
yeah and then standard conditions will
be played with permitted development
rights removed
yeah um i would personally put a
two-year development
of rather than three i will put two
years on it
so that they can crack on
the vote please thank you chad that's
the banter number four
pencil brown cancer frisky or
councillor leather poor cancer a lot
or cancer mcgrath or
unanimous chair thank you
c
i found an application i'm sorry
final application is 6d installation of
a storage container
and laura is going to take this one
really exciting this one laura i'll try
and make presentations as short as i can
so the applications for the storage of
the
installation of one storage container is
within the cash market car park
and we can move to the site location
i think members will be quite familiar
with where it is it's on the south side
of the car park
and so you've got the roughly ground to
the south and the playing fields to the
south
uh one of the accesses into the catholic
market car park
runs just to the west there that's the
next slide please
so i've got an aerial photograph and the
application sites
where the outlined area and red and it's
one of three existing
storage bays we're in the car park with
block work
walls
it's the middle of those three storage
bays and once it's got the
um green weeny bins in it and the white
storage bags
view from the west as you approach from
the park and playing fields
positioning of the storage container and
shows the
the size of the storage bay there
will be accommodated and then the
dimensions we've got
of the storage container so 6.1 meters
in depth 2.44 inch width
and then the elevations fairly standard
storage container up to
two point five nine meters in effect
so move on to material planning
considerations the
containers intended to be used by
visible town council for the storage of
landscaping and ground maintenance
equipment
the application sites located in the
second boundary of biddeford
and it's also within one of our
identified allocated sites
which covers the whole of the cattle
market car park site
as part of a regeneration site but it's
it's not considered that this
application will include any future
redevelopment
of the wider site so we have no
objection in terms of the principle
called st06
and number two the impact on the
character and the container would be a
very standard size and design and be
located within the existing block
walls so they would screen views of it
from most
aspects and they'll be seen in the
context of the
surrounding recycling facilities and
pumping stations so no objections are
raised in terms of policy
dmo4 in terms of residential amenities
uh distance of over 150 meters to the
nearest neighboring properties on the
chancellor's road so
officers have no objections there and
number four
access and contain wouldn't approach on
the existing
accesses into the car park so the
proposal will be keeping good policy
dm05 number five drone engine's flood
risk
the application site is located in the
critical drainage area and within flood
zone three
and you may note from the officers
report that the existing site already
has a concrete base
which will be retained so the surface
runoff and the site's not considered to
alter
and number six the ecology we've got a
completed wildlife trigger list
which doesn't raise any concerns about
potential harmful impacts
on protected species and due to the
nature of the site
no objections are raised in that respect
so the application is recommended for
approval thank you
thank you laura thank you
anybody want to make any comment no okay
senator you take the vote
that's
[Music]
are we charging the tank outs already
move on item seven on the agenda is the
appeals decision summary
there are no appeals for the period 12th
of may to the 21st of may
eight on the agenda is costs on appeals
and no possible appeals
now on the agenda is delegated decisions
agmv applications that are non between
12th of may
21st of may 21 10
is the planning decisions take
on pages 71 to 73 uh
between the 12th and main the 21st
century 71
72 73
that concludes those
item alone on the agenda we're not
extremely
public and there's no part two items
well
so i'll declare the meeting closed